[inaudible] has a military genius,
a tactician without peer at the age
of 35 having just ground himself,
the first emperor of France,
he said about conquering all of Europe.
His name was Napoleon Bonaparte,
and above all he was
a master propagandist.
He made use of his
extraordinary way with words,
do publish political
manifestos and newspapers,
and later his autobiography,
he regularly commissioned portraits and
sculptures and was acutely aware of how
to present himself in the best light.
Even when he made moves
to crown himself emperor,
he used propaganda and political.
Now to convince the populace
that it was their idea.
Napoleon has aroused one of two emotions,
hatred or loyalty.
Everything around him
seemed bigger than life.
Yet he has none of the physical
traits that we associate with power.
He was short at five foot
two had extremely pale skin,
small delicate hands,
and a large head set
on a short stout neck.
Despite this,
his inner self belief projected the
aura of invincibility that made him a
natural leader of men.
It led him to the dizzying
heights of Victory Am's,
the crushing despair of to feet.
And this week's biographics.
We discover the real Napoleon Bonaparte
in the spring of 1769 the tiny islands
nation of Corsica was under siege,
a hardy bands.
Of course,
it can.
Patriots determines to repel the French
army that had invaded their lambs.
They never stood a chance that after
a year of fighting death and carnage,
the rebels were a fetus.
The survivors trudge through the
mountains back to their homes.
Among them was that easier
and Carlo Bonaparte?
Let's easier.
It was six months pregnant.
It was the day of the Feast of assumption.
On August,
1517 69 went letizia.
It gave birth to her second child
and he was named Napoleon Napoleon.
His father gave up the flag.
Of course it can independence.
Once French victory was a shirt he refused
to fight on in the mountains with his
former Patriot holdouts,
the 23 year old university student
and ingratiated himself to the French
overlords and quickly took on the
trappings of French privileged.
It was something that his second son
would never forgive him for viewing his
father as a traitor who had
betrayed his countryman.
Collar then entered upon a law practice.
Before long he had won election
to the course of an assembly.
He became accepted among the elite.
Of course,
it can society and was viewed
with favor by the French rulers.
Yes.
The more successful he became,
the more it drove a wedge
between him and his second son.
In contrast to how he viewed his father,
the younger Polian Sims,
he adored his mother.
There's easier,
was a strong willed on the
woman of her 13 pregnancies.
She ended up with eight children.
Oh half disciplinarian.
She would tolerate no nonsense.
We have Napoleon would lead to reminisce
that all of his success in life was due
to the training of that he had
received at his mother's knee,
the and set foot on the French mainland
for the first time in the winter of 1778
his father having security in that
position at the prestigious Royal Military
College at Brienne in northern France.
Napoleon though he hated us,
accustomed to the warmth
of the Mediterranean,
the harsh climate,
shift him to the bone,
just top it off.
The skinny uncoordinated country
by could hardly speak any French,
any one of the facts that
he was a scholarship by
into country bumpkin and the
loyal Corsican with a strange accident
would have been enough to make the
bullies targets and yet somehow Napoleon
accustomed himself to life at Brienne.
His stubbornness and tough exterior
made him immune to the taunts of is more
privileged.
Classmates seem they,
along with his teachers,
lost interest in the Sullen,
always serious Bonaparte.
Napoleon,
he became a loner at the
age of 16 Napoleon began his
military apprenticeship as
a second left tenants training with
the country's most elite itinerary.
Eunice.
He knows his trade well and developed
into a skilled handler of arms as well as
a capable Hendra of men.
Yes,
the advancements that he had mapped
out for himself was slow in coming.
He soon realized that
hard work and application,
we're not enough to forge a stellar
military career position and money.
They also played their part and
he had neither by his late teens.
Napoleon found himself in a
state of frustrated inertia.
He knew that he was
destined for great things,
yet nothing was happening for him.
Simply he was bored to death.
What Napoleon needed was a cataclysmic
event that would up ends the existing
order in presenting with the opportunity
to grab hold of and shape the future.
Little did he know though that this
was waiting just around the corner.
On July the 14th 1789 Paris
erupted and revolution the spark.
There's unleashed the revolution
in all its Furio card.
When a crowd's took over,
an armory called hotel to invalid,
they grabbed its weapons and stormed the
Bastille prison in search of powder and
shot word spreads of
the crown success ends.
Uprisings began all over France,
grand juries and manor houses.
They were overrun.
The country was in great turmoil.
20 year old Napoleon was far from Paris
when revolution break forth cause they
not to revolutionary himself.
He welcomes the revolts which was shaking
the system of privileges which he so
despised.
After all,
it was this very system that prevented
him from achieving the advancement of
rank that he felt was due to him.
When the French republic was declared
in the fall of 1792 v ambitious courses
can,
he wanted to play a
pass formulating a plan.
He took a leave of absence from
the army and returned to Corsica,
which was now a part of France.
He was intent on entering local politics
and rising through the ranks until he
could assert its influence
on the national stage.
The course it can.
Governor,
however,
Rebuff Napoleon calling him
a big inexperienced boy and
Napoleon reacted to this
by setting up a power base
to oppose the governor.
He attracted a following of young cronies.
That's the establishment's
proved too strong fan.
Napoleon was forced to
flee to the mountains.
He ends.
His entire family were labeled traitors
and enemies of the father lands setting
south France.
In June of 1793 Napoleon was tougher,
more steely-eyed and more hard skinned
as a result of his unhappy experience in
Corsica.
The experience also caused
a mental displacement.
No longer a Corsican.
Well,
he was now 30 French that France.
However,
while that was going to have to be
molded to make it worthy of feminine,
if I didn't return to the
army as an artillery caps him,
he was quickly ordered too,
too long.
A city of 28,000 which had
broken into open rebellion.
This is dozens of this southern port.
It thrown their port,
open it to the British.
It was the French itineraries
job to prevent the British
from gaining a foothold
and just to subjugate the rebels.
The role of the ones that the British
were defending the city from their ships,
cannons Napoleon,
and knew that he had been presented with
the opportunity that could transform
his destiny.
Aristocratic officers had fled France
leaving a vacuum that the Polian was all
too eager to fill.
All the had to do was simply
proven itself on his commands.
Guns and suppliers were rushed in from
Provence and there's gunners were taught
to Mandan.
The regular infantry were intensely
retrains unto Bonaparte's direct
supervision.
He also began to display
the flashes of charisma,
which would forge an unbreakable
loyalty within his ranks.
On December the 17th he personally
led the assault of Fort Egg.
Relate his bravery and his
cunning immediately apparent,
throwing himself into the fray.
He fought with fury.
Unlike most commanders,
Napoleon led from the front.
Oh,
horse was shot out from under him and
it's an enemy ban at slashed him in the
fight.
Yes,
he continued to attack and his forces
quickly overcame the resistance.
Within hours,
10 British ships had been destroyed and
those that remained were in retreat.
The local people,
they would then subjugate us.
It was a stunning victory for Napoleon
and one that led to his promotion to
Brigadier General.
In the spring of 1795 Napoleon visited
Paris has ambition burning brighter than
ever.
While there he was charged with
subjugating the parisien mobs by any means
necessary.
He jumped at the opportunity grabbing
cannons and muskets in order to equip is
poorly armed forces.
He said his guns up inside the tutor
Rian positions that made it impregnable.
When the attack came,
Napoleon commanded his men to unleash
a merciless hail of fire upon them.
Waiting until he could see
the whites of their eyes.
He sends a barrage of great shots
that decimated the Parisien mob.
The enemy attacks us.
We killed a great many of them.
Now we'll,
there's quiet.
I could not be happier.
The podium wrote to his brother,
Napoleon was triumphant.
Within a month,
he had been made a full
general I just 26 years of age.
He was the commander of
the army of the interior.
Okay.
As a reward for his success against the
Parisien mobs was given command of the
French army in Italy.
There he was charged
with defeating France,
his enemies,
the Austrians,
along with that Italian allies
to push them back over the Alps.
This was his first opportunity
to fight on foreign soil,
and Napoleon was determined
to capitalize on this.
Prior to his arrival,
Napoleon's generals had already written
him off as a new accounts upstart with
illusions of grand.
Yet when Bonaparte's
arrived in the flashes,
generals quickly realized their mistake.
They had vastly underestimated.
Then you Camada.
He quickly put them in that place.
For nearly two years,
there in competence had seen the French
forces stagnating in the Alps with
nothing to show for it,
but a general sense of apathy and
discontent as the generals bit their lips.
Napoleon addressed the troops.
Soldiers,
you are naked and deal fed.
No fame shines upon you.
I will lead you into the most
fertile plains in the world.
Rich provinces and great city
as well lie in your power.
You will find their honor,
glory and riches.
The men were enraptured by their new
leader smiling and laughing in the midst.
It was unlike anything
I had ever seen before.
He picks up their spirits and made them
believe in themselves and infusing them
with passion.
He began molding them into
eight formidable fighting force.
Meanwhile,
the other European powers had become
very nervous about what was going on in
France.
The execution of their king and queen
led to the fears that the French
experiments in democracy would spreads
am's threat and their own kingdoms.
This led them to quickly move
against the new French government.
This led to a series of wars between
France and most of the major European
powers,
the of built his army into the most
efficient conquering force on the European
mainland.
Over the next three years.
He brought stunning victories,
not only in Italy,
but as far as Australia
and parts of North Africa.
There's a north African invasion force
was actually moving it's Britain,
which used Egypt as a trading route,
though he failed to bring
Egypt under control,
Napoleon was greeted as a hero on,
it's returned to Paris in 1799
yet he founds a nation in Tamale.
The governments had no money.
The Austrians and the Russians were
threatening to invade and some people even
wanted to bring back the royal family.
Rumors were flying of a cube with
the people on the army behind him.
Napoleon at took charge of the grand
assembly installing a new government that
was to be headed by three
provisional consults,
one of these three men with
Napoleon Bonaparte himself,
and it was he who everyone knew
was going to wield the power.
Immediately.
Napoleon took control.
He sidelined the other two consoles
personally rewriting the constitution to
make himself the first consult.
At 30 years of age,
Napoleon Bonaparte had risen from his
humble Corsican backgrounds to become the
most powerful
man in France
as the absolute central power in France.
Napoleon had inherited a nation that
had limped from one failed attempt to to
replace the rule of monarchy to another.
For many people,
the conditions they found themselves
in at the dawn of the 19th century were
worse than before the revolution.
They looked in Napoleon to
save them from their dispatch.
First though he had to save
them from the Austrians.
The Austrians had regrouped and gains
back and most of the lands that Napoleon
had secured during the Italian campaign,
the arch Duke Francis.
The second was intent on crushing the
course that can use he thought he could do
as he pleased,
as was his custom.
Napoleon decided to take the offensive
in the spring of 1800 he took his 40,000
strong army across the French Alps.
It was a harrowing track,
has men dragging field artillery and
provisions up steep snow covered mountain
rangers,
which towers to a height of 10,500 feet.
Men Donnie's on reason and there's the
grand army stumbled through this and
Bernard Pass.
They were in a state of utter exhaustion,
but the crossing it had
made in just six days.
The battle was joined on June
the 14th and at the day's end,
7,000 Frenchmen lay debt.
The Austrians who would finally retreat
in from the field of battle left 14,000
bodies behind the
totally spans grand army.
They had one again.
The Austrians withdrew and early the
next year signed a peace treaty with
Napoleon.
Great Britain was the only country
remaining in the podiums weight.
He was simply the supreme ruler
of the land mass that was Europe.
However,
Great Britain has unquestioned command
of the seas and fabulously Richard.
This point due to how colonial conquest
since boasting the greatest navy in the
wells Briston decided it was time to
holds the rise of the little general
president declared war on France on May
the 18th 1803 and it was at this point
in the Napoleon decided it
was time to invade England,
displaying the laser like
focus that epitomize the man.
He stated,
all my thoughts aren't
directed towards England's.
I want only for a favorable winds.
Two plants,
the Imperial Eagle on the Tower of London.
As it turns out though,
the French invasion of Great Britain
never materialized by September,
1805 war with Austria.
Now fortified by the Russians
was once again a priority.
If the ground's army was
being rushed from the coast,
do the heart of the Austrian empire.
Then on October the 21st the Royal Navy,
it smashed the combined Spanish British
fleet in the battle of Trafalgar,
leaving the French
essentially without a navy.
The British that left them safe.
The now on December,
the second day's here for Napoleon had
crowned himself as the first emperor of
the French in a lavish ceremony
in all but name and place.
It was just lengthy
coronation of the old kings,
which with one telling difference,
Napoleon that you
controller of his own fates,
place the crown,
all 80 jewel encrusted pounds
of it upon his own head.
Okay.
On December the second day,
you know,
five Napoleon found himself again
poised for Massell against Austria.
This time,
four to five by Russia,
this would prove to be the little general,
his greatest victory.
He deliberately abandoned a strategic
position near the town of Wooster in the
Austrian empire.
So that his army,
which numbered around 68,000
would appear vulnerable.
He then weakened his right flank,
so it was to look the 90,000 strong flow
into a trap if they their center open
to counter attack and the pony and cut
the line in two by 4:30 PM the allies
were either dead or foreign retreat.
The battlefields have
simply fallen silent.
The Battle of Austerlitz just like that
was over what it began as a great allied
opportunity to finally defeat and destroy.
Napoleon Bonaparte had ended
not only in their defeat,
but in catastrophe.
The grounds victory at [inaudible] was
followed up with a 21 day subjugation of
pressure.
Over the next five years.
Victory followed victory as one by one.
The European powers bowed to the
dictates of Emperor Napoleon only at one
European nation remains
to be brought to heel.
Russia
[inaudible] is a colossal army across the
Newman River run June the 24th 1812 to
intimidate Russia,
but it turns out to be
the undoing of his empire.
The Russians systematically
retreated and scorched the earth,
which drags the French
deep into their territory.
Then when they did do battle,
it was the bloodiest
day of Napoleon's Korea.
The French entered Moscow.
A week later,
I need to find it evacuated.
The retreat ended up
being even more costly.
Soldiers had insufficient clothing for
the freezing temperatures of an early
Windsor disease,
devastated the ranks and Russian
forces pursued them all the way.
A little over a six of the 600,000
men who marched into Russia came home.
This was a blow from which the little
general would never recover by now for the
political map of Europe,
it had changed the British,
the Spanish,
the Portuguese pushed the French
Bac over the Pyrenees in dependency,
love walk.
A grand coalition was formed with the
decisive victory coming at the battle of
Leipzig in October of 1813 known as the
battle of the nations that left 38,000
French dead or wounded
and 20 thousands captured.
Yeah.
Napoleon escapes only defines
open hostility back in Paris.
The legislative assembly,
the centers,
and even his own general stands on him.
He has no choice but to advocate,
which he did.
So in April of [inaudible] 1814 it was
agreed that Napoleon would be sent into
exile on the Mediterranean island of Elba.
After 10 months of exome,
the Polian had had enough somehow on the
night of February the 26th 1850 and he
managed to sneak past his gods and set
sail in a small boat for the mother
country within a handful
of loyal soldiers.
Miraculously,
they managed to avoid
the British warships,
stepping foot back on French soil.
He fixed his sights on Paris and it's
taking back what had been torn from
heaven.
After six days in just few men were halted
by an infantry regiments with strict
orders to detain him,
the podium straight ahead of his
followers and stood in their midst.
Soldiers either clouds if there is one
among you who wants to kill his general
and emperor.
Here I am.
His charisma that's done it again rather
than rush to taken captive the massed
infantry broken to wild applause.
Cheers of long live.
The emperor filled the air.
Suddenly he had an army.
As he closed it on Paris,
he drew more and more
support in one place.
Softer and other treats defected from
the royal army and joined the rebel army,
the writing that it was on the wall.
By the time you arrived in Paris,
let me the 18th and flat.
The podium was back in command.
The people,
they welcomed him as a redeemed here,
right
across Europe.
The allies were in shock and disbelief.
The devil,
it had been unchanged.
They would have to unite
one more time to stop him.
This time though,
they would have to totally destroy the
man so that there was no chance he would
come back.
Napoleon was declared an outlaw and a
disturber of the tranquility of the wells.
They mask their armies for attack.
The great reckoning it was that happens,
it would be delivered on a field of
Rye and clover just outside of a small
Belgian town called Waterloo.
On June the 18th 72,000 French soldiers
face day 68,000 strong allied force
under the Duke of Wellington.
While the fighting seemed even Napoleon
made many tactical errors including
launching his imperial guard too late.
Here's the most fatal error was to wait
until midday before ordering his initial
attack.
In order to the last of
the muddy ground dry.
This gave the Prussians
time do enter the fray.
Later on,
they smash it against his right
flank and the battle was lost.
Four days later,
Napoleon abdicated again,
but this time it would be no return.
He was packed off to the remote British
colony of Santa Elena at 46 Napoleon was
simply a man without a future,
the man of unstoppable ambition,
the man of action,
the amount of headlines he was confined
to reading the newspaper and gardening.
He died on May the fifth 1821 most likely
from stomach cancer days before when
he knew his time was up,
he had whispered to to one of his gods
to die is nothing but to live defeated
and without glory is to die every day.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button
below and subscribe button.
Doesn't do what it used to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
stuff from the archive
over there on the rice,
and as always,
thank you for watching.
[inaudible].